sometimes dealing with anomalies that
could destroy the world with a flick of
their wrist can get a little old sure it
definitely wouldn't be a good thing if
the devourer of worlds well devoured the
world or if
scp-001 when daybreaks turns us all into
weird melty zombies but it's almost
impossible to conceive the sheer scale
of destruction that an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario would cause
you'd almost be numb to it if you even
survived in the words of scp-2430
creator joseph stalin the death of one
man is a tragedy the death of millions
is a statistic okay he didn't actually
say that but it's an appropriate quote
either way today we're talking about a
much smaller pettier kind of evil sure
this anomaly can kill people and has
many many times in fact but where it
really gets its kicks is in making you
feel like crap on a more emotional level
it's scp-056
ironically known by the nickname a
beautiful person because on the inside
this self-obsessed monster is anything
but beautiful this crafty creature spent
what potentially could have been
hundreds of years around humans before
the scp foundation eventually located it
and apprehended it meaning you may have
even run into it at some point or
another before it was rightfully
imprisoned how do you know if you had a
brush with scp-056
well it's difficult to know for sure but
perhaps the biggest indicator is that it
probably annoyed the living hell out of
you you see
scp-056 is a sentient shape-shifter with
a subtle mind-warping ability whose
entire reason for existence is using
those abilities to make everyone around
them feel incredibly inadequate they
don't have any kind of consistent or
true form only a consistent ethos and
that ethos is anything you can do i can
do better and we mean this in the most
literal sense whenever scp-056 is left
with a person an animal or even an
object the second all eyes are taken off
of it it'll become a slightly better
version of whatever it's encountering if
that thing in question is capable of
thinking or feeling it will not feel
good about this development just like we
said it's probably not going to bring
the world to its knees but it sure would
suck to know scp-056
its lack of a consistent form makes
scp-056 a little difficult to think
about visually which was also the reason
it was so hard to catch but for the sake
of consistency we'll present it here
with one of its favorite forms a woman
who's a real dead ringer for perfection
famous actress scarlett johansson of
black widow fame personally i liked her
as the computer and her but that's
besides the point so what is it really
like to experience
scp-056's anomalous effects first hand
well we'll take you through a little
crash course in anomalous insecurity and
frustration let's say that this creature
in human form is one of your co-workers
when the foundation discovered it it was
working in the fashion industry but who
knows what job it could have held before
then if it worked in your office it was
probably that one irritating co-worker
who always wore nicer clothes than you
had a brighter whiter smile and much
better hair while you were thanklessly
toiling away on the reports for the
latest financial quarter zero five six
was schmoozing with your boss on golf
lunches scoring perfect games and
promotions one hole in one at a time of
course they'll tell you about it at the
water cooler like everyone else who's
feeling inadequate maybe you buy
yourself a new car a vintage cadillac
convertible that makes you feel more
like a gangster than an office drone
awesome that'll make all those feelings
that you're not good enough go away you
even buy yourself a stylish pair of
sunglasses and start cruising around
town with the top down hoping that
everyone sees how cool you are now but
when you are stopped at a red light you
see someone approaching in the lane next
to you it's the latest rolls-royce
phantom in jet black and who would be
behind the wheel but scp-056
in armani shades that are much nicer
than yours it grins and nods to you in
the mirrors and you can feel your soul
shriveling up inside you only to be
replaced by rage and resentment maybe
later that month you and all your
co-workers are at a bar enjoying drinks
of course scp-056 is the best-dressed
one there and is telling all the most
interesting stories your jokes don't get
at any laughs but 056 is bringing down
the house with every word feeling
ignored you decide to get everyone
around on you 056 is a designated driver
in its new rolls-royce so you just
decide to get them a pepsi instead
however by the time you return to their
stool they're nowhere to be seen a tall
glass of coca-cola with ice cubes is
sitting on the bar next to their seat
perhaps one day you finally snap and
decide you can't take it anymore you'll
meet scp-056 after work and put the
showboating jerk in its place at long
last you sneak up on it in an alley with
a knife in your palm and swing for it
but your blade never makes contact
scp-056 unleashes some high-level
jiu-jitsu move on you easily knocks the
knife from your hands and beats the
living hell out of you when you're later
convicted of attempted murder all you
can do is scream they made me do it
again and again in your prison cell envy
can do crazy things to a person but wait
there's more really if you lose your
mind from an encounter with scp-056 you
still haven't done too badly while its
methods of attack are more commonly
psychological as we alluded to earlier
scp-056
is definitely not above committing some
pretty horrifying acts of violence
scp-056 was discovered in its clothing
design job after causing an unusually
high number of murders suicides and
mental breakdowns among its co-workers
however things took an even more
unpleasant turn when the foundation sent
personnel to detain it
scp-056 reacted poorly to the show of
potential force and turned into
something even more dangerous than the
foundation plan for it in getting under
control we don't know exactly what it
transformed into due to scp foundation
redactions but our guess is for what it
transformed into would either be a giant
monster a rambo-esque unstoppable super
soldier or something like one of those
huge killer robots from robocop pick
your favorite down there in the comments
but whatever the case it caused the
unfortunate deaths of 17 agents and 10
civilians the incident was blamed on an
employee at the company going postal and
deciding to kill a bunch of innocents
which
technically wasn't untrue
not long after foundation operatives
were able to tranquilize as cp-056
perhaps you think this nasty little
monster decided to mellow out a bit
after being contained but if you did
think that i'm afraid you'd be dead
wrong it just decided to start
terrorizing foundation staff with its
infuriating anomalous abilities instead
wait until you see this compared to a
lot of entities locked up at the scp
foundation
scp-056 really lives in the lap of
luxury it has a well-furnished room easy
access to members of staff and is given
permission to interact with any object
it desires as long as those objects
aren't anomalous why is this
euclid-class anomaly with over 17 dead
foundation staff members to its name
given so much leeway well to answer that
remember the ethos anything you can do i
can do better and this holds true
whether we're talking about physical
appearance or one's capacity to commit
tremendous acts of violence the
foundation is forced to cater to most of
scp-056's whims or it will become a hell
of a lot more dangerous in response to
any kind of external resistance see we
told you it'd suck to have known this
thing and nobody knows that better than
the employees of the scp foundation who
are forced to interact with it on a
daily basis for containment and testing
first let's take a look at some of the
forms it's occupied since it began its
time at the scp foundation when a
researcher brought in their beloved
pooch
scp-056 decided to flex on it by
becoming a beautiful well-groomed
labrador retriever when a younger female
staff passed it it decided to once again
take on its scarlett johansson form when
speaking to a group of other researchers
about intelligence it became a female
researcher with an iq score 30 points
higher than the top scoring human
researcher on site when it took a trip
to the containment site's gym where the
guards and mobile task forces exercise
and train it decided to take its flexes
to a more literal level it transformed
into a ripped hunky bodybuilder who
strutted into the middle of the gym and
bench pressed 250 kilos no problem this
was 30 kilos more than the strongest
human guard working at the site its
commitment to being the best is so great
that when left alone in its containment
chamber it will sometimes literally
transform into a nicer couch than the
one the foundation provided for it
doesn't it just make your blood boil but
wait there's more just in case this
wasn't absurd enough the foundation felt
like testing the limits of its anomalous
abilities in particular they were
extremely eager to see if 056 had a
secret default form they left it alone
with a single security camera in order
to observe what it transformed into when
not being observed and can you guess
what happened it turned into an even
higher quality security camera and
stared back while the transformations
can only take place while zero five six
isn't being observed it's very astute at
creating periods where it can't be seen
or interacted with vision or camera
feeds have been known to briefly go
foggy in order to facilitate a
transformation it's fitting that 0.56
being the ultimate diva will only ever
let people look at it on its own terms
it also seems to get off on causing
shame and the degree to which that
statement is metaphorical is well open
to interpretation staff members made
insecure by its antics feel compelled to
enter its cell and verbally berate it at
which point 056 will shame them even
harder and send them out with their tail
between their legs it's like every toxic
friend rolled into one nasty package
curious as to what else scp-056 was
capable of the foundation conducted a
few other tests between scp-056
and their personnel here they discovered
that 0.56 seemed incredibly responsive
to intent when a d-class was sent in
with a knife and the intent to kill 056
transformed into a lean athletic man
before disarming and killing the d-class
a somewhat attractive d-class female was
sent in with a bottle of wine 056 became
a beautiful woman and accepted the wine
before taking a sip and spitting it back
into the d-class's face a mixed gender
pair of d-classes were sent in next with
no real intent 056 became an attractive
woman in a well-tailored business suit
who looked over the pair before kicking
them both out 10 male d-classes were
sent in after that 0-5-6 turned into a
beautiful woman in a low-cut dress and
simply waited until the 10 men were
driven mad with desire and began
physically fighting one another for her
affection she watched them doing this
for seven minutes before laughing and
leaving the sim squadron to duke it out
alone in another test a female staff
member with level 4 clearance who was
also judged to be the most attractive
woman on site which seems like an hr
issue that the ethics committee should
probably look into was sent into 056's
testing chamber 056 became quote an
extremely aesthetically pleasing woman
who displayed a large lexicon and
understanding of management skills
unquote the two spoke for around 90
minutes until the level 4 staff member
stormed out in a rage recently 056 has
requested access to the internet saying
that the foundation has been unable to
provide it with enough syncopates and
that via the internet the whole world
will be able to see its face if ever 056
got onto youtube and transformed into a
more successful scp channel i just don't
think we'd be able to take it thankfully
this request was denied now go check out
scp minecraft world destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in the crucible and
scp-2430 immortal hitler clone for more
anomalies you really just want to punch
in the face